what was that gnarly injury I was 11
years old as an MTV Sports and music
festival I crashed with Bob burn Quest I
broke my hand I broke my foot and I
fractured my skull and what was crazy
about it was the reaction of the
community we lived in because they're
like oh
you guys got what you deserved you're
doing these sports that we don't
understand and look what happened to
your son your parents take a step back
and maybe reconsider letting you go
forward into chasing the stream of
snowboarding with my mom she's like well
I just got to get him back on the ramp
because I would cry if I couldn't go to
the skate park after school was My
Punishment like if you don't do the
dishes you can't go skate tomorrow and
I'm like scrubbing all the dishes I just
truly loved it so she actually like
helped guide me back into skateboarding